vaccines are on the ballot the first
thing I want to say is ladies and
gentlemen don't take medical advice from
podcasters and talk to your doctor about
what's right for you but this story is
very interesting as per the sentiment
held by people in this country and how
it relates to to RFK Jr versus Trump and
Biden check out this headline according
to the Daily Mail quarter of Americans
say coid 19 shots are unsafe and that
they know someone who died from one as
2024 wannabes to sandz and RFK Jr take
skepticism on the campaign Trail I think
this number is Highly Questionable that
one in four Americans know someone who
died that is a a strong like we I think
we'd hear in the news about that many
people having died that being said I
want to
clarify if there are 10 people people
and they all know Bill and Bill dies and
then you ask these 10 people do you know
someone who died they'll all say yes oh
that's a great Point yes it's it's still
just one people that know them who know
Bill might also say yes you know my
friend and they're like oh yeah it's
like oh I know some Dad yeah my friend's
friend bill you know what I mean so we
don't know exactly what this means also
I didn't get asked so they didn't do a
holistic it actually does say um despite
several attempts Ian Crossland did not
respond to our question I never will
emails Ian I want to stress uh YouTube
calm down uh I am not talking about this
cuz I care to talk about the efficacy or
issues around vaccines that's for you
guys and your doctors or whatever I do
think it is politically important that
people feel this way because there's a
question of uh we're talking with luk
rowski about RFK Jr and Luke was saying
there's a good there's a good
possibility that RFK could take votes
from Trump because Trump was bad on
vaccine mandates and lockdowns and RFK
Jr is good and I say yeah but the you
know the core ideologies of RFK Jr and
Trump are so different you you're I
think you're going to find somebody who
says I'm willing to forgive Trump on a
lot of things because he's anti-woke
he's challenging these government
contracts no new Wars Etc and RFK Jr
called Columbus Day indigenous people's
day and that's like a red flag for a lot
of people yeah so uh that being said let
me read a little bit they say Americans
are growing more skeptical about the
safety and effectiveness of vaccines and
politicians from left and right are
echoing these fears in their campaigns
to win the White House polling this week
shows that while most voters trust shots
for Co 19 MMR and other bugs Millions
more have changed their minds in recent
months and no longer see them as safe
the surveys come as health Chiefs worn
of rampant online misinformation linking
injections with death and autism and
that ior maon an antiparasitic drug
typically Us in animals can treat co9
again don't take medical advice from a
news organization either despite these
warnings and their implications for
public health two politicians are
building vaccine skepticism into their
2024 campaign it's a santis and it's RFK
but here's here's the image look at RF
K's face it's the most hideous
angry so here's here's some questions
they they asked uh is the co 19 vaccine
safe in August of 2022 73% said yes and
18% said no as of October 2023 66% say
yes and 24% say no that's really
interesting they ask do you know someone
personally who died from side effects of
the coid 19 vaccine 24% said yes 69%
said no they ask is increased vaccine
use linked to kids getting autism 10%
said yes in April of 2021 as of October
this year 16% say yes and then there
here's a big one if there was a major
class action lawsuit against
pharmaceutical companies from for
vaccine side effects How likely would
you be to join the lawsuit 24% very
likely 18% somewhat likely not very
likely 22 and not likely at all 25 with
11 not sure the plurality is not likely
and they ask is iaed an effective
treatment at in September of 21 10% said
yes as of this month 26% said yes and I
want to stress for the 800 of the time I
am just reading polls calm down YouTube
yeah not all vaccines are the same and
it's not fair to classify them as such
the qu the well tested medicine is very
different than untested medicine I like
not having polio the sure and and the
main point here is what is Shifting the
American perspective on this issue well
let's first find out how many people got
hold here this is an important aspect of
this one cuz if it's just a thousand
people then I'm I'm going to stop
reading Daily Mail like that is a gross
misc categorization of one in four
Americans that's a good point it could
be it could be a highly biased thousand
to 1500 people think it's uh it's r m
reports and the annenburg public policy
Center at the UN of the University of
Pennsylvania I'm wow R M's usually
pretty good but r m and uh University of
Pennsylvania if it was just r m I'd say
gets a lot right you know we'll see the
both of them together I say okay that's
really interesting again this is not a
poll about whether or not they vaccines
actually cause issues it's something is
Shifting the perspective of the American
population this is going to play a big
role I'm wondering however you know when
Luke said Trump was bad on vaccines and
lockdowns so RFK Jr may pull from him
yeah but Biden was worse Biden and
Democrats were 10 times more into
lockdowns and and and vaccine stuff than
Trump yeah but Trump was in when all the
worst stuff happened when it came to the
lockdowns at least I gu he was he was
the he was the first guy said we're
going to shut down for a couple weeks so
and I think you know cuz you mentioned
how RFK Jr and Trump are very different
ideologically but I mean so many people
who vote I mean just this is just people
I know who voted for Trump they're not
like uh ideological really they just go
in and vote Trump because they don't
like the other person like a lot of
people voted like that so if they see
RFK Jr and he's really good on this
issue and this is a big thing just Co in
general really affected so many people
you know so if he's good on it that
might just be enough for people um I
think that that's an issue that could
flip a lot of trump voters I'm just
really
curious what do you think is causing
this shift in the American public's
perception I mean the corporate press
has been insistant on vaccines and and
and you know we hear as good stewards of
of of information we don't break any of
these YouTube roles how could these
people possibly hold these views I think
that it's the fact that people mistrust
you know trust in the in the media and
Trust in the government had been going
down for a long time prior to coid and
Co just annihilated a lot of people's
trust there's a lot of people that that
are horribly embarrassed by the the way
that they supported the government that
they believed things that the news said
and I think that that this is the the
the result of that if you have a society
that generally has a declining in trust
and a and honestly we are more cynical
than we've ever been you know it's like
Being Earnest is now looked at as
something to be mocked and so believing
the what the news tells you is is
something that will get you mocked
nowadays if you say oh I believe if you
have enough followers on Twitter you can
say I believe anyone anything could be
anything at all and someone's going to
say you're wrong and you're dumb for
believing it there is there is this
there is this impulse that people have
to be the the one person that has the
inside track and so people are afraid to
believe things they're afraid to admit
that they believe things because they're
going to get mocked they're going to get
called out they they're going to be
people that say you're dumb for
believing that didn't you know how could
you believe that I mean I see it all the
time on in my Twitter feed oh how could
you believe that you know this and how
could you not so I think that that
disincentivizes people to believe
anything they're afraid to say that they
believe anything they're afraid to say
oh I I think this is actually true and
they don't know where to go to get
information that they feel like they
that should be trusted well let me uh
let me piggyback off of that did this
article even link to the study to the
poll or are they just like a poll said
one they specii I don't even trust this
story that I think they're lying I don't
even think it's they cited rest M and
university did they link to it but what
do you mean like to the Cross tabs yeah
like show me how many people they pulled
if they pulled a thousand people and and
saying that extra to 350 million I'm
going to be like go directly to when you
say that there's like a shift here like
has people has there really been polls
asking this question before you know we
don't really know if this reflects like
a shift I I they it looks like they had
previous polls asking the same question
oh yeah you're right now that aside the
let me see if I can pull P up the the
cross tis that aside I think that
rushing this the co vaccine the warp
speed thing tweaked a lot of people like
that was that was like I'm afraid for my
life because of Co and I'll do anything
you say mentality and then when we saw
rises in like
myocarditis that's like
terrifying yeah and Trump still like
brags about warp speed right when they
ask him about it he says you know how
proud of he literally brags about
anything Poss something I kind of wanted
to ask you guys about cuz I know like
you're I don't know if you consider
yourself like a Maga guy but no um I'm
voting for Trump yeah uh he's far from
perfect but he's the best it just seems
like there's a pretty big distinct like
difference between the the Maga movement
and the things that Trump actually says
now uh but I know he represents
something more so RFK Jr I gotta say he
was a big disappointment um because you
know I'm kind of a single issue type of
guy and he came out really strong on
Ukraine you know very well and then uh
people started calling him sorry 1500
adults yeah that's this it's just such a
disingenuous title of the article 1500 I
mean that's what do you mean poll finds
mhm poll finds Fair Point you should
have said one in four 1500 po like
that's not 350 Milli PS are typically
like a, to
150000 actually above average consider
that yeah right I consider that it's
highly manipulative it's it's just an
absolute waste of a that is it is most
disingenuous misleading title say that
one in four Americans think it when they
pulled 1500 people Ian I don't think you
understand how pull I understand
completely how they work and they're
massive manipulative many they are manip
most people understand that they're not
trying they're not supposed to be but
the way the article phrased it makes it
extremely manipulative but the point
that I'm making is most people
understand that if you are talking about
polls you're not talking about a poll of
a 100,000 people like the the Civic
actually what was that civic.com they
have polls that because they're so
expansive there's 300,000 people yeah
crazy good on them but still most most
polls like they're not hitting you know
but this was a shock title to get clicks
it's Daily Mail I mean junk news it's a
rest M and and uh uh what is it the uh
uh I want to get the name right the uh
anenberg public policy Center so the way
polls are done is through there's a
scientific polling method where they
take a wide range of individuals they
Whittle down their their networks
there's uh bad things and huge margins
of Errors when when it's done improperly
but you basically try and create a
cross-section of
America isolate it down to the key
demographic areas where you notice these
ideological shifts and then pull a
thousand people and then figure out what
the percentages are and then try and
like that's it's it's normal and and and
you can you can argue there's a margin
of error in these things but right 3,00%
margin of error or something what were
you going to say I felt like you were I
interrupted you on accident oh no I was
just wondering it wasn't really related
I was just wondering what you guys think
of RFK Jr
I mean have you had him on here I like I
like the fact that he canceled on us oh
did he I like the fact that he's counter
to the narrative that the government
puts out I think that he's terrible on
literally everything except for vaccines
yeah I would say so again with the
foreign policy like he was he's very
good on Ukraine and he explains it well
he interviews people uh you know he had
his own podcast he was interviewing
people I know this guy named Ben ablo
who wrote a book called How the West
brought War to Ukraine it's like a very
short book that came out right after the
invasion explaining how the US provoked
it so he interviewed him and he really
understands the issue but when it comes
to Israel people smear him you know they
they called him an anti-semite and he
just went all in on Israel and when this
thing happened it's just like he says
that the US needs to support an Israeli
sustained military campaign I need to
issue a clarification this is the data
comes from two different polls r m and
Edenberg did different polls they're
just being mentioned in the same article
you got the M was 1500 the other one uh
no no no uh 1500 1,110 was was r m okay
r m was actually one of the most
accurate polls in I think 2016 and 2018
I think I think consistently actually
when when the polling data comes out
showing how many people voted r m almost
always Nails it for the record I really
really like accurate polling like if you
can get 10,000 people and you get an
accurate read out of what those 10,000
people think maybe you can be like you
know the isue is in this city you know M
does five polls and then they say here's
here's here's what people are saying 51%
49% then the election happens and they
go yeah it was they were right 5149 how
how about that and they do it five times
then they come with another poll I'm
like okay I I I I'll lean towards
believing them and I just want to push
back a little bit on what you said if
the if you're dealing with a country
with 330 million
people why is
10,000 acceptable and and 15 no I'm
saying in a small town of 10,000 and you
pull all 10,000 people I like those kind
of plls or even if there's like maybe
15,000 people and you pull 10,000 of
them you need like 70 or 80 it's
accurate you need an if you really if
you want to come out and make a
statement that one in four Americans
believe something you better pull at
least 90% of them right you're not
asking for a poll you're asking for an
election asking for a real poll not
these junk polls aren't the best you
know polls are kind of the best you have
when it comes to the things you're
looking to find out when it comes to
like election polling they're not part
they're they're better lazy they're
really the only cuz that's how it's
always been done like just deal with it
kind of mentality well you're saying
this just like the best we can do say we
should saying it's just when it comes
you know especially elections when you
like it is kind of your best indication
of where people are at is polling and
and the question is are the has the
polling organization been accurate in
the past and then if we look at rest M
and find that they typically are very
accurate you discrediting them because
you don't like polling methodology makes
no sense I discredit them because they
pulled 1100 people and then they claimed
to speak for 33 the article did I think
you know if you're saying that they
should just PLL more people I think
that's a 100% most polling most polls
actually say 47 people of those ped said
yeah or that's what they should say not
the shock the shock statement you're
complaining about a news organization
not the polling institutions no I think
you know there speaking of polls there
was just a poll conducted by I forget
the name of the place but it was about
Israel and Gaza and it said the majority
of Americans support a ceasefire it said
the majority of Republicans do which
like I almost didn't believe it uh you
know I think that a lot of Americans do
want to ceasefire but to like it was
like 80% of Democrats and 56% of
Republicans you know they pulled like,
1500 people it's a Trum Trump people
don't want war yeah a lot of yeah you're
right I think a lot of the ordinary
Trump people don't want war even if it
is Israel but unfortunately the magga
politicians seem to uh favor it I think
one issue well I I don't want to derail
another issue I have with polling is uh
and this is a little bit off off Bas is
that I feel like it is a self-fulfilling
prophecy some sometimes if you see if
they pull people and they're like 80%
want this then people see that and
they'll be like yeah me too like that
that can kind of that that's why the
their political polls will often try and
skew in favor their politician to
convince people that our guy's the
winner because people want to vote for
the winner so weird if you see the polls
the election polls right now I mean
Trump is leading the pack still by so
much so that indication like we don't
know the exact what the exact vote would
actually be but from constant polls
showing him so far ahead it gives you an
idea I got a question for you we've been
looking at these polls uh RFK entering
the race as an independent do you think
that he pulls more votes away from Trump
or from Biden I think Trump I actually
do think Trump uh again because just you
know the Trump the average Trump voter
might not be so ideologically drawn to
Trump uh more of a I know so many people
that voted for Trump in 2016 it was just
a vote against the establishment uh same
thing in 2020 just a lot of people that
didn't like Biden I also knew a lot of
people that didn't vote for him that did
it because they were kind of sick of it
but
I think this Co issue again when it
comes to Americans issues that really
affect them I mean this is something
that really affected Americans uh me
personally I you know my wife's business
closed down we moved out of this city we
you know changed our whole life and it's
something that people are going to
remember you know this is this was a
very serious time in in in America you
know it's kind of like if you think back
on it you know I was living in Brooklyn
at the time with the lockdowns and it
was just looking back like it was so
insane and everybody went along with it
and I saw Andrew Cuomo when I would go
get a coffee on the TV with his nipples
sticking out telling us to stay in our
houses and it was crazy and I was so
angry about it Angry enough that we left
and you know I'm fortunate enough that I
was okay you know my wife's business
closing down we were fine we were able
to get out move out to the country but a
lot of people don't didn't have that
option so you know I think he could
definitely pull some Trump voters that
still feel that anger about what
happened in 2020 yeah man now what I
would love to talk about is the vaccine
the co vaccine or the series of Co
vaccines I I don't want to make start
going too hard on it on YouTube I know
that YouTube is requested that we don't
you know spla our opinions about it I
would love to because I think this is
just so many people were traumatized by
this experience of the co vaccine or the
co virus and the vaccinations you know I
left New York before this happened you
had to show them your vaccination papers
to go into a restaurant I mean that is
insane
that is stuff that the antivaxers were
saying a few decades ago that people
were like you not even a few decades ago
not long before that people were like
that's crazy that'll never Happ 2020
they were like they're going to start
doing these passports I was like shut up
no they're not and they did they tried
live I can't imagine it they tried doing
the app and nobody would do it they
wanted a social credit score so you know
what's
interesting get uh so RFK Jr Israel so
that model what New York City did and I
think other cities did it I think DC
might have did it for a little while you
know the vaccine passport was modeled on
Israel's green pass Israel like was very
you know vaccine mandate and lockdowns
and stuff and I believe it was called
the green pass so kind of one of the
most intrusive things that they did to
us was based on Israel's model China on
the other hand they had their uh
lockdowns that were really insane but
they actually they tried to implement
some sort of vaccine mandate in Beijing
and people were like no we're not doing
that and then they gave up so it's kind
of interesting just the differences uh
in the countries like it's not something
you would really expect that you would
just assumed China had like a vaccine
mandate but they didn't like in that
sense of you have to walk in and show
them your card or scan something um but
yeah it's based off Israel's uh model
wow I was thinking the other day how
funny it was and maybe it's funny
strange not funny haha that it was Co
they were like it's so dangerous that
you have to get tested to find out if
you even have it and I'm like okay
really did you hear I'm proud of so is
that I've never taken a CO test and that
wasn't really like intentional but I
just never did I took and I tickled the
back of my nose and I was just sneezing
and blowing all this snot out dude it
felt so good I was outside doing it I
like oh yeah rolling around you should
take one that sounds felt really nice
okay that's awful yeah so now everyone
knows but back to politics rough we I I
I don't I don't see uh I think RFK Jr
pulls from both Trump and Biden but two
to one Biden from Trump Biden to Trump
think so okay yeah because RFK Jr is a
is a he's a liberal yeah his core is
liberal it's true he's Kennedy he's got
the Kennedy
name's running on that Ian's pointed out
when he talks about his family that his
family would not vote for Trump they
would vote for Biden they might vote for
RFK I think that's just like a really
simple way of breaking down what this
might be they did vote for Biden I don't
know what they're up to these days I I
should talk to about it I mean Biden's
mental degradation has become very
apparent if the poll is for Democrats
Five Points towards RFK meaning your
average person has a 95% chance of
voting for Joe Biden that still means
means 5% vote for RFK Jr whereas the
poll for Trump supporters is like one M
what are your feelings on Viv
ramaswami uh he says you know a lot of
good things but I think his foreign
policy he's pretty off base uh on some
things with you know Taiwan for instance
he he wants to commit to defending
Taiwan but he also says things like oh
once we get semiconductor Independence
then we're not going to uh you know
worry about Taiwan anymore but he's
still saying that you know to deter War
we should you know commit to war with
Taiwan and also his plan to end the
Ukraine war he's like I'm going to get
Putin to sever his military alliance
with China and that's how we're going to
end it it's not really a realistic plan
you know they don't really have a formal
military Alliance they've been building
one up and doing drills and stuff uh but
also just they're not going to go for
that I mean trust has been destroyed
between the west and Russia you know
there's going to have to be some uh real
good faith negotiations and you know
trying to just get something like that
like China and Russia have really built
up up their trade relationship in recent
years and they're very relying on each
other now they're not just going to give
that up for the US that could change in
eight four or eight years somebody will
come in and say you know what forget
that we're going to move you know move
NATO into Ukraine forget that guarantee
we gave you we need to rebuild trust
before you could do something like that
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time